all right
um
that's what
okay
so
okay
uh
back
[Music]
me
thank you for having me yeah
okay let's go
oh mr swanson
okay good morning everybody thank you
for being here
and i have joining me some speakers who
are very worried about the fate of
health care in america
as it affects their families and all
americans
they are renee saltzman and
her daughter emily and jeremy
jeremy right here and josh feynman
penny's dad penny couldn't be with us
today but josh is and he'll tell their
story
we'll hear their stories in a minute let
me say a few things once again the loss
of ruth bader ginsburg touches all of us
she was an amazing lady
she fought against all odds brought
equality for women
got on the court and brought equality
for everybody she will be missed
and as i mentioned to put someone on the
court whose views are the
exact opposite of ruth bader ginsburg
at a time when she asked as our dying
wish
that we wait till the next election to
choose somebody
is just appalling that donald trump
would go ahead and do that and that
mitch mcconnell
would follow him to do it but
he's done that and now we want to talk
about the nomination of amy coney
barrett
this is troubling news for hundreds of
millions of americans
and their health care amy coney barrett
has said
that aca is wrongly decided
she will be the swing vote on that court
and if she gets on the court it's a
virtual certainty
that over 150 million americans
hurt health care will be hurt
dramatically
a vote for amy coney barrett
is a vote to decimate the health care
that so many americans need there are
130 million americans
who have pre-existing conditions we'll
hear from two families whose kids have
them
but you could be a senior you could be
somebody with diabetes who's 55 years
old
you could be somebody with asthma who's
28 years old
in amy tony barrett's world if she gets
on the court
it'll be virtually impossible for you to
get insurance
and once the protections for
pre-existing conditions are eliminated
if you have a child who has a serious
illness no insurance company will take
you
you'll have to watch your child suffer
the outrage
they're also over 30 million seniors
who get reduced costs for very expensive
prescription drugs
lost if obamacare is repealed which is
what amy coney barrett wants to do
and there are close to 10 million
americans whose only health care
is through the aca they will lose their
health care as well
donald trump just as recently as this
morning said one of the reasons he's
putting
tony barrett on the court is to get rid
of america's health care to get rid of
the aca
that should not stand and we are asking
new yorkers and americans to call
senators all over the country and say do
not let
this happen of course
there are other issues as well
women's health and a woman's right to
choose is completely at risk
labor rights are completely at risk we
could end labor unions
under a court with coney barrett
protections for our planet as global
warming increases
could be gone under
a coney barrett addition to the court
kids like emily kids like emily
are in the crosshairs unfortunately
with this appointment americans don't
want disappointment
the vast majority of americans say wait
for the next president and then make the
appointment
the overwhelming majority of americans
want to keep their health care
and not have it dramatically slashed
and that's why cody barrett does not
belong
on the court we are here today to say
that there are so many reasons she
should not be added to the court
at the top of the list is health care
but we also know
there are so many other issues where
she's against
the american people she's claimed
if justices read the laws the way she
does
they would quote have to invalidate the
entire health care law
that word sound shivers down the spine
of these families and millions of others
[Music]
millions of others her record also makes
clear
that she will work hard to eliminate roe
v
wade and a woman's right to choose that
she will
at the very least so cut it back that it
we won't even know it existed
her views are so far out of the
mainstream
on health care above all but on so many
other issues as well
this is a reprehensible power grab
it's a cynical attack on the legitimacy
of the court
engineered by mitch mcconnell and donald
trump
and we are going to do everything
everything everything we can to fight it
but the best way people when they say
what can they do to help
let your friend let you call senators
across the country
especially republican senators and let
them know you want to keep your health
care
you want to keep if you're a woman you
want to keep your freedom
and reproductive freedom if you care
about the globe that you want to keep
us fighting global warming if you care
about working people
you want to keep labor rights call call
call we can stop this nomination
if the american people rise up
and say no and put heat on republican
senators who are now bowing to donald
trump's
awful wishes to get rid of your health
care
and so much else i am now going to
call on renee saltzman
and jeremy saltzman and emily um
who will talk a little bit about their
situation
um and honestly this is not about
republicans or democrats
and it's not about politics it's about
right
and wrong and our daughter emily
suffered a traumatic brain injury at the
age of seven due to an accident
she's now 12 and she continues to go
through recovery
she has a pre-existing condition so
everyone here today
either yourself or a family member
a loved one a friend you know somebody
that has a pre-existing
condition my daughter should not be
denied
health care because of a pre-existing
condition
so no american
we feel should be denied health care
because of a pre-existing condition
so our family is using our voice
to say we're not going to allow this to
happen
i will not let my daughter be
discriminated against
and we have the best gift we have our
voice
the power of our voices so i'm begging
you please
please use your voice
it's never been more important get out
and vote please
let me just say every american every
american
whether they're two years old or 90
years old
is one diagnosis away from a
pre-existing condition
and under the trump world with coney
barrett on the court you will never be
able to get insurance
and your health will suffer dramatically
we now have mr fryman um who will talk
about
uh his daughter mr findman will talk
about his daughter penny
thank you senator um yes i just want to
talk uh so my daughter also uh she
couldn't be here today she actually
lives in um
an assistant care facility and under
covet hasn't been able to get out
thank god for that facility and the care
they're giving her and um
and that wouldn't be that wouldn't be
possible without
so many protections that we get under a
number of our laws
both medicaid which he has also private
health insurance
and i know that the salesman spoke um uh
very eloquently about
pre-existing conditions and how quickly
that can put you in trouble with
insurance if that protection isn't there
another one that's that's come up with
penny is um is lifetime
caps which is in danger and as the
senator said you're one everybody gets
one diagnosis away from having
pre-existing conditions for the rest of
your life
anybody is one diagnosis or one accident
one illness away
from hitting a lifetime cap you can run
through
believe me i've seen it you can run
through hundreds of thousands of dollars
in medical bills in a single year
sometimes less than that
and um to think that under
uh if that protection is taken away and
her private insurance and she still
needs private insurance for a lot of her
care
if that's taken away she would hit even
those generous caps within a year or two
so i mean this is um i know for the salt
as well for me this is a
this is an issue that really does
transcend politics this is something
that we really need to look out for
our fellow americans and even for
ourselves i mean this can really happen
um to anybody and so i'm here for um to
speak for penny she can't do it for
herself
and also to tell everybody that these
are your rights as well that we need to
all
protect lifetime caps are also protected
in the aca which judge coney barrett
wants to eliminate and let me just say
we're one vote away
the vote was 5-4 in the court with ruth
bader ginsburg upholding aca
if she's replaced by judge coney barrett
that will be flipped and all these
things will go away again a vote
for coney barrett let me just let me
just let me just finish what i'm saying
a vote for coney barrett is a vote to
strip away health care from
over 100 million americans it will
happen
if she's on the bench so once again new
yorkers americans
raise your voices yes sir
they will not do any good he said it for
three years
he's never done it it won't work
you're next
no because i believe
first that the whole process has been
illegitimate
and second because she's already stated
that she is for overturning the aca
i will not be with them
look um we will use
every tool in the toolkit to slow things
down
but mitch mcconnell has so commandeered
the senate has so defiled the senate
there are fewer tools and they're less
sharp of what is there we will use
other questions thank you everybody
should play no role no role it's the
issues the fact that she will repeal
aca she will support a woman's right to
choose
and repealing aca no matter what an
executive president does
will not restore it period you need the
law to do it
yes okay thank you everybody
oh
thank you everybody nice to see you it
doesn't even give up
get that out of the way
oh